I do things that make people look at me
weird. My roommate asked if I was having
a stroke. My neighbor definitely thinks
something is wrong with me. And my
girlfriend calls my bedtime rules
annoying. But here's the thing. I sleep
better than I have in years. I focus
better. I get more done with less
stress. And the only thing I changed
these weird little habits that nobody
else does. I brush my teeth with the
wrong hand every single morning. I stare
at the sky for 10 minutes like I'm
waiting for something to happen. I
answer emails sitting on my floor on
purpose. I take fake commutes to
nowhere. And when I'm stuck on a
problem, I pretend I'm an alien. Most
adults are running on autopilot. Same
routines, same exhaustion. I stop doing
normal. That's the whole secret. People
think I'm disciplined. I'm not. I'm
lazy. I just designed my life so lazy.
Works in my favor. Weird works.
Normal is why everyone's exhausted.